ABOUT, THIS OUTCOME THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO SEE.
>> EXPLAINED LAST NIGHT ON THE
CHANNEL JOE BIDEN ESSENTIALLY
TAKING CREDIT FOR THE CEASE-FIRE
BETWEEN ISRAEL AND HAMAS.
IT WAS ACTUALLY BROKERED BY
EGYPT NOT BY THE UNITED STATES.
LET’S BRING IN "FOX & FRIENDS
WEEKEND" CO-HOST PETE HEGSETH
AND WILL CAIN.
HEY, PETE, YOU KNOW, FOR HIM TO
BE TAKING CREDIT, THAT’S LIKE
HIM SAYING THAT HE WAS TAKING
CREDIT FOR KILLING BIN LADEN
WHEN WE KNOW THAT, IN FACT, HE
SAID DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON’T THINK THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA.
LET’S NOT DO IT, BOSS.
PETE: THAT’S TRUE.
ULTIMATELY WE KNOW THE OUTCOME
OF THAT KILLING BIN LADEN.
WHAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN NOT THIS
CEASE-FIRE POSITIVE IN THE STATE
OF ISRAEL WHETHER THEY HAD
SUFFICIENT TIME TO EXACT THE
PRICE FOR FIRING INDISCRIMINATE
ROCKETS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
WAR.
AND THIS PARTICULAR CASE ISRAEL
DID WHAT IT NEEDED TO DO FOR A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO
ATTEMPT TO DISSEMINATE A
TERRORIST NETWORK THE QUESTION
IS IT ENOUGH AND WHAT ROLE DID
HE GREWLY PLAY ISRAEL HAS A
RIGHT TO DEFEND ITSELF THEN THE
HAMAS CAUCUS.
THE FAR LEFT WING OF HIS PARTY
PRESSURED AND PRESSURED AND
PRESSURED HIM.
THERE WAS A LOT OF MORAL
EQUIVALENCY BETWEEN THE TWO
ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
WE STILL SEE THEM DABBLING WITH
AN IRAN DEAL WHICH WOULD ENRICH
THE IRANIAN REGIME AND ALLOW
THEM TO GET CLOSER TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS WHETHER THAT’S THE
REGIME SUPPLYING HAMAS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN WHETHER
THIS IS A GOOD THING.
ALL I CARE IS WHETHER OR NOT
B.B. NETANYAHU AND ISRAEL FEEL
LIKE THEY GOT THE PRICE PAID
FROM HAMAS THAT THEY NEEDED AT
THIS MOMENT FOR DETERRENCE.
AINSLEY: WILL, WE WANT YOU TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS TOPIC, BORDER
PATROL, THEY GET 32 MEXICAN
MEXICAN NATIONALS.
THEY CAME OVER.
THEY ARE DRESSED IN CALM
FLOWNEL.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
WILL: WELL THAT IT WAS AN ARREST
THAT REFLECTED EXACTLY WHAT I
SAW A FEW WEEKS AGO WHEN I WENT
TO THE ARIZONA BORDER FOR "FOX &
FRIENDS," AINSLEY.
I SAW FIRSTHAND THE CAMOUFLAGE
DISCARDED ON THE LOADOUT ZONES
THERE WHERE THE MIGRANTS TAKE
OFF THE CARTEL ISSUED
CAMOUFLAGE, THE CARPET SHOES
THEY USE TO MOVE QUIETLY THROUGH
THE DESSERT, BACKPACKS FULL OF
WHATEVER IT IS THEY BRING INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
IT JUST BACKS UP EVERYTHING THE
SHERIFF MARK LAMB AND OTHERS
SHOWED ME THERE IN ARIZONA.
WE GOT PARTICIPATE IN A BORDER
PATROL ARREST.
GUESS WHAT?
THOSE MIGRANTS WERE ALSO MEXICAN
NATIONALS WEARING THAT EXACT
OUTFIT RIGHT THERE.
THAT IS A GREAT ILLUSTRATION OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IN ARIZONA.
BRIAN: YOU KNOW WHAT, WILL THE
PEOPLE OF ARIZONA IT GOES BEYOND
POLITICS BECAUSE HAVE YOU FULL
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS IN
DEMOCRATIC COMING OUT SAYING
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE AT THE
FUTURE.
THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA DON’T CARE
ABOUT REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS,
THEIR LIFE IS BECOMING CHAOS
BECAUSE OF THAT POROUS BORDER.
WILL: TWO QUICK POINTS ON WHAT I
HEARD.
IT’S ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE IN PLACE
WHERE THE RULE OF LAW DOESN’T
APPLY NOBODY OBEYS THE RULE AND
SECOND QUALITY OF LIFE.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF SOMEBODY
IS ALWAYS WALKING THROUGH YOUR
BACKYARD AND NOBODY YOU CAN CALL
TO SOLVE THAT IT’S A QUALITY OF
LIFE ISSUE.
STEVE: WE HAD 20 MINUTES AGO
THAT CONGRESSMAN FROM AT THE
PRESENT SEE A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CALLED THE GOVERNOR OF TENNESSEE
AND SAYS HEY, CAN YOU TAKE SOME
OF THESE MIGRANT KIDS?
AND HE SAID NO.
WE DON’T HAVE ROOM.
SO WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
REPORTEDLY FLYING THEM INTO
AIRPORTS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
THEY HAVEN’T TOLD ANYBODY AND,
YEP, WE HAVE GOT THE KIDS COMING
BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT THE
FOLKS TO KNOW.
PETE: WHY WOULDN’T THEY?
THEY RAN SCARED FROM IMAGES THEY
DIDN’T WANT THE MEDIA TO SEE
FROM THE BEGINNING AT THE BORDER
BECAUSE OF A POLICY THEY
INSTITUTED.
AND RATHER THAN ADDRESS THE
ACTUAL ISSUE AT THE BORDER AS
WILL IS TALKING ABOUT, THEY TRY
TO MAKE THE PROBLEM QUIETLY IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT GO AWAY.
I’M SURPRISED THEY ARE EVEN
ASKING STATES OR NOTIFYING THEM.
OFTENTIMES THERE IS NO
NOTIFICATION PROCESS AND PEOPLE
ARE RELEASED AND MAYORS ARE LEFT
TO DEAL WITH IT.
THIS IS NOT A BORDER ISSUE.
THIS IS COMING TO A TOWN NEAR
YOU.
BRIAN: GO AHEAD, AINSLEY WANTS
TO KNOW WHO IS GOING TO BE ON
YOUR SHOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE SURPRISED.
SO CAN YOU.
STEVE: CLOSE YOUR EYES BECAUSE
IT’S IN THE TELEPROMPTER.
WILL: HERE’S THE GREAT THING
USUALLY PETE AND I LIKE TO BE
SURPRISED AS WELL.
LUCKILY IT’S IN THE PROMPTER.
SALAZAR, THE ISRAELI AMBASSADOR
TO THE U.S. AND THE U.N. AND
THERE YOU HAVE IT RIGHT THERE.
NANCY GRACE.
AINSLEY: SHE IS ALWAYS A GREAT
GUEST.
WILL, YOU HAVE BEEN DOING A
GREAT JOB ON PRIME.
I BET YOU ARE EXHAUSTED.
YOU WORKED LAST WEEK WHEN BRIAN
WAS ON SHOOTS AND YOU WORKED ALL
WEEKEND AND WORKED ALL WEEK AND
YOU ARE WORKING THIS WEEKEND,
TOO.
WILL: ONLY THING I HAVE GOING
FOR ME KILMEADE IS ON THE SAME
SCREEN WITH ME.
THE GUY IS WORKING 18 HOURS A
DAY.
I’M EXHAUSTED I DON’T KNOW HOW
YOU DO IT.
BRIAN: I WILL SAY, THIS THE FACT
THAT YOUR FULL SCREEN HAS YOU
WITH A BEARD BUT NOW WE ARE
LOOKING AT YOU LIVE WITHOUT ONE.
IT MAKES ME WONDER WHO MAKES
THAT DECISION?
DO YOU HAVE A FASHION
CONSULTANT?
WILL: ONE OF US HAS A BEARD
RIGHT NOW.
STEVE: PETE HAS A POLICY HE DOES
NOT SHAVE DURING THE WEEK.
HE ONLY SHAVES ON THE WEEKEND
WHEN THE PAYCHECK.
BRIAN: WHO COMES UP WITH THAT
CONTRACT.
PETE: IT’S IN MY CONTRACT.
GET A BETTER AGENT, BRIAN.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE WATCHING YOU
THIS WEEKEND.